well despite the good news of the
vaccine and now the stimulus package
our hospitality industry is still just
crippled
the mirage announcing that it will
temporarily close all
operations monday through thursday
starting in january
erko mana joining us now live from the
mirage tonight to explain
orko
well denise the mirage is just the
latest resort here on the las vegas
strip
to reduce its hours experts say it's
because of low demand
during the coven 19 pandemic and the big
question now
is how long these economic effects will
continue
i think it's unfortunate i mean
certainly we don't want to see it happen
more coveted 19 closures on the las
vegas strip mgm resorts announcing the
casino restaurants and other amenities
at the mirage
will only be open from noon on thursdays
to noon on monday
starting january 4th this pandemic has
had an economic toll
analyst jeremy aguero says many people
still don't feel comfortable flying and
cannot afford traveling during the
pandemic there are already midweek hotel
closures at the mirage mandalay bay and
park mgm
planet hollywood and the encore have
made similar moves aguero says a january
closure is due to no conventions like
ces
taking place and a rise in covet 19
cases
the combination of those things is going
to mean that demand is going to be
very low and supply is going to need to
adjust that's exactly what we're seeing
but some tourists think all property
should stay open people want to be here
now more than ever because i mean this
is one of the only places you can enjoy
now
it may be wrong that we came but i mean
we're actually taking precautions you
know we're taking care of ourselves
aguero says the current vaccine rollout
will inspire more confidence and travel
but a rebound will take a while we're
really hopeful by the time we get to the
fall
that you know we'll start seeing
additional significant convention
activity
back in las vegas and maybe even some
special events aguero adds that even if
things return to normal by the end of
2021
a full economic recovery for las vegas
is still a year and a half to two years
away reporting live outside the mirage
on the las vegas strip tonight orca mana
8 news now